so this show is so good uh from the
first few minutes i was hooked how did
you know that this was such a good fit
for you because you're incredible in
this oh my gosh thank you i
that's so kind honestly when i was
reading the script
every couple of pages i was getting more
and more excited and also i remember
asking the writer i just said are you
rooting around in my brain how have you
how how did you do this
um i i really i just feel like i was
supposed to play sam yeah i was gonna
say do you feel like this is the show
that you have been waiting for yes
absolutely
that's awesome i love that and you know
what's great about a medical drama for
us it's really fascinating to hear all
the medical jargon but i can imagine
that's a little overwhelming for you
what was it like kind of wrapping your
brain around all that
honestly for me it's been a dream i grew
up wanting to be a surgeon before i did
my first play and then decided i was
going to go to theater school instead of
drama school uh or instead of medical
school sorry
and um and and so see what i mean i i'm
better at medical jargon than uh than
even my own
native theater schtick um
i i just love it i love being able to
get in there and learn
about the procedures and the processes
that are behind them and the rehearsals
and the surgical equipment and i mean
the bone saws everything i love it i
think it's like the coolest thing i've
ever done every time i get to do it
oh that's all well then that just makes
your job even more fun yeah truly pretty
cool yeah your two loves kind of
together um i think what sets this show
apart from other medical dramas is of
course this amazing complicated tense
father-daughter relationship jason
isaacs is just so quick you guys have
fantastic banter what's it like working
with him on set thank you jason's
wonderful and i agree i think what sets
our show apart and why it was so
interesting to me i love family dramas
and i love medical shows and i'd never
seen a family drama that took place in a
hospital before but when you when you
see that these family dramas that
revolve around the sort of family
dynasty work i mean it's why we love
succession um
there's something about how interesting
it is
when the stakes are so high for a family
and then the stakes are also life and
death because it's in a hospital i
couldn't get enough of the script and to
to make something like that work to
balance those two elements at the same
time you certainly want to work with
someone who's incredible and capable and
of course jason isaacs is both of those
things
he's brilliant and he's smart and
acting with him is such a joy and such a
challenge and we just have so much fun
and i feel for him because he's a girl
dad in real life and sometimes he looks
at me and just says i don't want to say
this to you this is mean
it's true because there's some harsh
moments and they're so quick you're
almost like did you just say that yeah
he did
he sure did he sure did dr rob griffith
is not for the faint of heart no
are you a harry potter fan did you ever
have a moment where you're like oh cool
lucius malfoy is playing my dad
so it's been very funny the number of
that exact text message i've gotten oh
my god lucious malfoy is your dad people
are freaking out about it and it's
really really sweet to see i love that
the harry potter fandom and the one tree
hill fandom are coming together
uh i can't wait to show them what we've
made yeah it's pretty cool these are
really die-hard fandoms so let's talk
about one tree hill because you know the
the drama queen's podcast has just been
so exciting for the fans what's it been
like for you spending so much time with
bethany joe joy lens and of course
hillary burton
it's been so great for us you know we've
we've all been friends since we were 21
years old yeah and to be able to come
back and and
reclaim our show
and do it together just as women and as
executive producers finally and as the
creative team behind it it's been so
much fun it's a little spicy
it's a little healing it's very funny
and we're finally getting to see what
the fans have always seen now we
understand
why the show
is evergreen to so many people why it
lasts and
why they've loved it because at the time
we had no idea what was happening we
were just doing a job
and now we we see it from that sort of
30 000 foot perspective and you know
there's my gals like right behind me on
the wall all the time
and
it's just so special for us
i think it's an opportunity that
so many people wish they could have and
not a lot of people get and we went out
and made it and we're really proud of it
yeah and it's doing so well did you know
it would be so healing
no
you know when we first started to talk
about it when i called the girls because
i had my podcast already i've been doing
work in progress since 2019 and when the
pandemic hit and good sam was put on
hold uh the three of us were on a group
facetime one day and a couple days later
i just said guys i had a thought
uh
i think we could do this
and
we knew then that our our
adult bonds had been really healing for
us and and we knew that it was going to
be special but we had no idea what we
were in for we didn't know that we were
all going to be in tears you know at the
end of the first episode we didn't know
we just didn't know what was ahead and i
think that
there's some of the magic that was in
the show is is magic we've been able to
recreate on our own terms with the
podcast and that feels
very cool for us
yeah oh i can only imagine that's
amazing well as you already know fans
are loving it so that's awesome um you
know what's really cool about the show
too is we get to see
sam obviously has this very stressful
job at times but she's the piano to
release her stress what do you do to
kind of uh get over a stressful day i i
definitely have hand tics as well so i
think that's where
sam and i are very similar um i like to
clean organize label
i like to get everything just in its
place which works well uh for surgical
sort of specificity on set as well my my
big sort of stress relief at the end of
2021 was i started making christmas
ornaments oh i saw that on your social
media yeah i started making christmas
ornaments with some of my girlfriends my
intention was to make like 10 of them to
go with all my cute you know red and
white
christmas story kind of
uh decor and then
i can't explain it i just got addicted
it was like this very meditative
repetitive thing and before i knew it
i'd made 76 of them and now obviously my
brain is like well we got to get to 100.
so
the thing that i might do
i'm like do i do that on my flight back
to toronto do i just bring my little kit
what do i do i'm already trying to
figure out how i'm gonna get to triple
digits oh my god i love that well just
to wrap it up what are you most excited
for when you come back to toronto
oh my goodness i mean obviously we're in
very tumultuous time this new coved
variant is incredibly contagious we have
to be so careful
and you know ontario's just gone into a
lockdown again which
i know it's so stressful for people i i
do understand that it makes sense given
how cold it is you know you can't really
hang out outside and gathering indoors
and groups isn't safe right now yeah i'm
really hoping that we see
um that omicron you know burns fast and
hot and then kind of does away with
itself the way it has been in south
africa i mean my fingers are crossed for
all of us
but
it puts a little wrench in the plans i
there were restaurants i was excited to
get back to i wanted to go eat another
big mac bow at dilo i can't do that now
so i don't know i i think you know i'll
come home and try to catch up on some
shows i haven't seen and a movie here
and there and then when it's safe for
all of us to gather again i'll get out
into all the restaurants in my
neighborhood that i love and the local
coffee shops that i think are so great
and
all of the you know small businesses
that i like to be a patron of i think
after another wave of closures though i
know they'll be temporary people will
need our patronage so it's a win-win for
me because i get to go and support my
friends and also eat delicious things
and that's really all i ever want to do
i love that so much um such a pleasure
getting to talk to you this is awesome
and congrats on the show it's uh very
exciting for him to see it thank you so
much i really i can't wait we're so
close and i'm just i'm like vibrating
yeah yeah yeah that's a good feeling
well congratulations
thank you
you